[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro bienvenidos a escala en
parís es una emisión de radio france
internacional en colaboración con
france24 en español el año pasado se
cumplieron 500 años del encuentro entre
hernán cortés y el clan emperador dirían
después los españoles de technology clan
moctezuma y posteriormente se han
seguido una serie de celebraciones que
culminarán el año entrante 2021 cuando
se conmemora en los 500 años de la caída
de tenochtitlan en mexico ser gruzinski
es historiador especialista de américa
latina y miembro de la escuela francesa
de roma autor de innumerables obras y
sobre todo especialista también en
hernán cortés ser brosinski bienvenido a
esta escala en parís muchísimas gracias
se cumple y darme se cumplen decíamos
500 años precisamente de la llegada de
hernán cortez a mexico y siguen estas
conmemoraciones durante dos años hay
lugar para que se conmemora algo a que
se debe recordar hoy la presencia y la
existencia de hernán cortés bueno yo
solo puedo contestar como francés o como
europeo no puedo
adoptaron un punto de vista mexicano
latinoamericano 500 años eso quiere
decir 500 años de expansión europea o
sea hernán cortez es un actor que
empieza uno de los procesos
fundamentales de la historia europea
su extensión fuera de sus fronteras
continentales en este sentido es un
personaje sin duda alguna muy
interesante al mismo tiempo polémico se
le califica de aventurero de grande
estratega militar de ambicioso
algunos de estos adjetivos corresponden
a lo que era ese personaje o ninguno de
ellos yo diría que hoy en día lo que
usted acaba de decir con mucha razón es
la visión del siglo 19 enfocada sobre
figuras personajes y con mucho
romanticismo yo diría que es
indudablemente es uno de los actores
mayores del renacimiento en general
tanto como leonardo da vinci porque
porque con él empieza en la serie de
procesos fundamentales para américa
latina pero también para la historia
europea yo creo que lo hoy en día o tal
vez porque vivimos en un mundo
globalizado podemos
a esta conquista de méxico este
personaje dentro de un conjunto este
conjunto significa maquiavelo y cortes
es una especie de maquiavelo
indudablemente que aplica la política de
maquiavelo a un ate que era
completamente exótica perspectiva global
quiere decir también que hay un actor
por atrás de la conquista de méxico que
hoy en día conocemos muy bien que es
china conquista de méxico es un momento
de la historia ibérica absolutamente
conectada y paralela al intento de
conquista de china por parte de los
portugueses mismos años en mismas fechas
justamente es una cosa que tiene que
olvidarse dentro de la historia dentro
de la descripción de lo que fueron los
procesos de expedición llegada a méxico
conquista y lo que está sucediendo
digamos del otro lado hablemos un poco
precisamente de esta competencia que se
va a desarrollar entre españoles
portugueses y el papel que juega cortes
a través de lo que fueron los envíos de
oro y plata a españa al reino lo que es
importante entender en la época lo que
es importante como el petróleo hoy
son los pueblos productos pimienta
canela de las islas de las especies de
las molucas
los portugueses llegan a través del
océano índico y quieren ocupar china
para estar más cerca de esta fuente de
riqueza la el único camino que les queda
a los españoles es el camino occidental
por panamá o siguiendo a magallanes o
cruzando méxico entonces las conquistas
son dos avances y hoy día es de una
actualidad increíble para acercarse al
imperio de los ming o sea a china y ahí
vemos de la lado portugués una figura
que se asemeja mucho que es también
diferente y de hernán cortés él se llama
tom y pires es el jefe de una cosa que
al mismo tiempo una embajada y una
expedición de conquista
tú me pides va a encontrar al emperador
shington en nunca usted acaba de
recordar el encuentro entre hernán
cortez y tirado allí para un historiador
la cosa fabulosa es que estos hombres
más o menos salidos de la nada se
encuentran con los dos hombres más
poderosos el uno de américa y el otro
del mundo asiático a partir de esta
lectura serviu shinsky hasta qué punto
se puede hablar del corte es como un
activador de lo que sería después el
desarrollo del capitalismo en todo caso
en esa parte de américa que sería
américa latina' posteriormente yo diría
que es mucho más usted genera son con
cortes y llega el mundo de este producto
capitalismo del siglo 16 o sea la
integración de la economía americana en
la economía europea pero con costes
llega también la cristianización llega
también la imprenta los libros y yo
hablaba más bien de occidentalización y
por eso cortes es muy importante cortes
decide
transformar reconstruir la ciudad de
mexico cortez decide llamar este mundo
mexicano nueva españa como los franceses
en quebec van a hablar de nueva francia
como se hablaba de nueva inglaterra
entonces eso quiere decir que no es
únicamente un acontecimiento de la
historia española o mexicana pero de la
historia europea con cortes empieza este
este movimiento
muchas veces dramático terrible de
duplicación de europa europa quiere
reproducirse del otro lado del océano lo
que algunos llaman la primera
mundialización de que exactamente por
eso una perspectiva global hoy en día es
la mejor manera de renovar el tema con
esta occidentalización empieza también
una reacción una transformación que se
llaman los mestizaje el mundo mexicano
del siglo 16 17 es el mundo que hoy en
día los franceses pueden ver en la
película de miss the hub la causa es un
masa de color en las calles de mejor
juego hay indios pero hay españoles y
portugueses franceses negros
africanos y hay chinos o sea es ese
mundo por eso es muy importante para
europa es una anticipación de lo que
estamos viviendo ahora de ahí la
verdadera importancia de langosta es el
crea por primera vez en el continente
americano una situación en la que a
través de la expansión la colonización
del capitalismo que usted acaba de
recordar pero también de la de la
transformación de los imaginarios de la
alfabetización la imposición del español
pero también el hecho de escribir la
revolución alfabética es el equivalente
de la revolución digital no son todas
estas revoluciones que podemos asociar
con el nombre de hernán cortez ahora
bien en marzo del año pasado el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador dirigió una carta al rey de
españa pidiéndole que el reino de españa
pidiese disculpas de lo que él llamó es
los agravios cometidos durante la
conquista española cuál es la opinión
que usted merece que le merece usted
como historiador esta demanda del
presidente mexicano es un gesto político
y no es el gesto de un historiador yo
puedo decir que es algo que se enmarca
en una tradición del siglo 19
de considerar la conquista de manera
bastante maniquea entre buenos y malos
los malos son evidentemente los
españoles y el súper malo es hernán
cortez y los buenos son los indios yo
creo que es una de todas maneras y no
puedo hacer una crítica política y sólo
le cabe a los a mis amigos mexicanos yo
llegué a que no debemos olvidar que en
esta conquista de un tercer elemento la
llegada de los africanos que son
esclavos de olvidado si entre los altos
de mexico en todo exactamente no es
únicamente un tipo de película de
vaqueros entre cowboys e indios hay
también esta parte africana y eso
introducía una dimensión mundial
planetaria que hace que no es únicamente
un acontecimiento nacional es mucho más
y lo que a mí me interesa es la
significación que puede tener hoy en día
para nosotros europeos o en las escuelas
para nuestros alumnos que hacen historia
del mundo en las clases en los liceos
colegios de mi país ahora en este
sentido y tomando en cuenta que usted
también es un fino
de méxico vivió varios años allí lo que
llamó mucho la atención es que corte
sigue siendo un personaje que pese a
todo esto que usted ha mencionado
podríamos decir está vetado de la
política y de la historia mexicana los
mexicanos las élites mexicanos
construyeron un pasado y continúan
manipulando un pasado para ellos el
pasado sigue siendo sumamente importante
para actuar en el presente o minado y
dominador exactamente legado
conquistador ahora y el el sencillo
hecho de utilizar el pasado en mi país
el pasado se se olvida completamente en
europa también haya méxico es un país
que a diferencia de brasil por ejemplo
en el cual el pasado sigue un
instrumento político fundamental el
pasado prehispánico el pasado colonial y
claro que para enfrentar los cambios
actuales del mundo
una vez más se recurre a una
interpretación oficial en este caso del
pasado ahora la pregunta sería una
visión nacional del pasado mexicano
puede tener algún sentido en un mundo
globalizado en el mundo en el cual una
parte de la población mexicana vive en
eeuu por ejemplo yo lo dudo pero es mi
opinión como europeo y no me atrevería a
opinar sobre la política oficial del
gobierno mexicano
ahora bien vivimos en esta serie de
interpretaciones de conmemoraciones
también un periodo de revisión de la
historia y hablamos decíamos de un
personaje que es bastante polémico llama
la atención incluso que cadenas de
televisión como history chanel o
amazonas también han desarrollado series
sobre cortes de este personaje tan tan
polémico finalmente qué opinión le
merece precisamente esta reescritura de
estos personajes de personal yo diría
que estas tres películas que conoce un
poquito son bastante arcaicas o sea es
retomar la visión del siglo 19 o sea son
productos son mercancías no son
productos científicos para hacer reñidas
tienen que corresponder a ciertas normas
que son todavía las de las películas de
hollywood o de las novelas del siglo 19
está esta visión romántica del personaje
positiva o negativa es para mí una de
las intimidades más interesantes del
mundo aparentemente completamente nuevo
pero que cultivó a funcionar con
elementos dramáticos
del siglo 19 implica esto que hay una
necesidad más que nunca de redescubrir a
este personaje para situarlo en lo que
éste me equivocaba es fundamental para
comprender lo que es la situación actual
yo diría que
los usos del pasado son múltiples yo
participé en varios programas en
francia- cómo utilizar la conquista de
méxico para enseñar historia del mundo
en clases en las cuales la mayoría de
los alumnos son musulmanes no son
católicos no son nacieron en francia
pero no tienen el pasado oficial de mi
país y yo creo que una manera de
revisitar este pasado es de utilizar
esta conquista de méxico pero también la
conquista de china puesto de mexico
victoria de los europeos conquista de
china derrota absoluta de los europeos y
los programas que tuvimos las
experiencias fueron bastante positivas
para implicar para interesar para
utilizar la conquista de méxico para
entender qué significa colonización que
significa cristianización y usted sabe
resulta muy difícil hablar de hijos de
argelinos marruecos del cetera de la
colonización francesa hablando de méxico
se puede entrar en el debate y
pedagógicamente y para mí es la cosa más
importante la conquista de méxico es un
elemento
sumamente útil del pasado no de españa y
de américa del pasado europeo pues muy
bien estamos llegando ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle a search luzinski
historiador especialista de américa
latina y conocedor de corte su presencia
en este escala en parís gracias a search
muchísimas gracias a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]